- We rewrote this episode
four or five times.
It was really hard to
write about depression
and make it funny and make it
active.
Abbi's mom, who is played by
Peri Gilpin,
most popularly known from
Fraiser, her storyline
is depressing too and it
was just hard to make two
storylines about depression
funny.
- The light, I mean the sad
lamp and Ilana's heightening
of the sad lamp.
- That was one of our
trickier episodes this year
and I love it.
- I love it.
- But this depression shit,
that's next level bitchy.
Kinda digging it, my dick
is a little bit hard.
I hope you never get better.
- Thanks.
Working with RuPaul
Charles was such a dream
and finding out that he
just like knows the show
and liked it.
- He plays Marcelle who is
Alana's new boss at this
restaurant she's working at.
It is like a different
character for him too
but it also is so him.
I think the character is more
stern that Ru actually is.
- And also like containing
him into the manager
of a restaurant.
- I don't know what kind
of strong island honkies
you brought up in here up
in Tanya but this is not
Billy Joel's go to Dave and
Busters, okay?
- It was just such a
crazy like American honor
to have Ru on our show.
I've been watching RuPaul
on TV for my entire life
but to put Ru in the Broad City
world,
it felt so right.
It felt like he's been
here the whole time.
- [Director] Action.
- Kick fuck me, put your fucking
foot in my goddamn pussy.
You know?
- Let's start again.
(laughs) This is such a dream
come true.